hi there I'm Liz a site reliability
engineer or essary at Google and I teach
google cloud customers how to build and
operate reliable services and I'm Seth a
developer advocate at Google focused on
infrastructure and operations and Liz
and I are here to settle things once and
for all which is better
DevOps or sre whoa there Seth hold on a
second I'm not sure you're really
looking at this in the right way but
first of all maybe we should clarify
some things what do you think DevOps is
Seth so that's a great question Liz back
in the day operators and developers had
a lot of contention developers used to
throw their code over the metaphorical
wall and operators were responsible for
keeping that code running in production
operators had little understanding of
the code bases and developers had little
understanding of operational practices
but developers were concerned with
shipping code and operators were
concerned with reliability this
misalignment often caused tension within
the organization so if I understand you
correctly you're saying that a
developers were responsible for features
and the operators were responsible for
stability being the developers wanted to
move faster to get their features out
faster and the operators wanted to move
slower to keep things stable I could see
how that would cause a lot of tension
exactly so DevOps is a set of practices
and a culture designed to break down
those barriers between developers
operators and other parts of the
organization
I break DevOps down into five key areas
first reduce organizational silos by
breaking down barriers across teams we
can increase collaboration and thorough
put second accept failure is normal
computers are inherently unreliable so
we can't expect perfection and when we
introduce humans into the system we get
even more imperfection third implement
gradual change not only are small
incremental changes easier to review but
in the event that a gradual change does
make a bug in production it allows us to
reduce our mean time to recover making
it simple to rollback fourth we need to
leverage tooling and automation and
fifth we need to measure everything
measurement is a critical gauge for
success and without a way
a measure of our first four pillars were
successful we would have no way of
knowing if they were so Liz you've been
an SRE at Google for over 10 years now
do you think any of the way that I
describe DevOps aligns with your
experience as an SRE it's sounding very
familiar because if you think about
DevOps as a philosophy essary is a
prescriptive way of accomplishing that
philosophy
so if DevOps were an interface and
programming language you might almost
say that sree is a concrete class that
implements DevOps
let's take a look at how that is so Seth
when you talked about eliminating
organizational silos what I thought
about is the fact that we share
ownership of production with our
developers and we use the same tooling
in order to make sure everyone has the
same view and same approach to working
with production when you talked about
accepting accents and failure as normal
what I thought about is the fact that
similar to many DevOps practitioners we
have blameless post-mortems
where we make sure that the failures
that happen in our production systems
don't happen the exact same way more
than once and we accept the failures as
normal by encoding a concept of an error
budget of how much the system is allowed
to go out of spec and then third we
talked about making fragile changes and
when you said that I thought about the
fact that we canary things that we roll
things out to a small percentage of the
fleet before we move them out for all
users and then fourth when you talked
about leveraging tooling and automation
what I thought about is the fact that we
try to eliminate manual work as much as
possible so we measure how much toil we
have and then we try to automate this
year's job away and then fifth when you
talked about measuring everything I
thought about exactly that measurement
of measuring the amount of toil that we
have and measuring the reliability and
health of our systems I really like that
class sre implements DevOps
we should get that on a shirt or
something but just like a class in a
programming language there might be
additional functions or methods that
don't necessarily correspond to that
interface or the class might implement
multiple interfaces do you think s Ari's
like that I absolutely think that's the
case because of the fact that essary
doesn't do things in the exact same way
that other people that implement DevOps
elsewhere might want to do so we'll talk
a little bit more about those
differences
such as
how exactly s ellos work which are a
very specific concept that we implement
in order to make SR a successful great
well that settles it then it turns out
that DevOps and sre aren't two competing
methods but rather close friends
designed to help break down
organizational barriers to deliver
better software faster thank you
everyone for watching please be sure to
check the description below for more
links and don't forget to subscribe to
our Channel stay tuned for our next
video where we will discuss the
differences between SL is SL OS and SL
A's